Asalam alaikum.
How are you guys doing?
It's your brother MH with another video
in the car. It's been a long time since
we done one of these, but sometimes they
can come out more natural anyway because
it's less performative. You know, I can
be a little bit more intimate with you
and we can talk, me and you, on these
very important issues that are on the
news. Of course, what's been on the news
is the death of Charlie Kirk, an
individual who I've actually made a
video about in the past and challenge to
a debate and all these kind of things
because he was a political adversary,
especially visav the issue uh relating
to Gaza and the genocide. But the
senseless murder of this man uh by
probably by some crazy lunatic uh
far-left lunatic has left a lot of
people from both sides
uh of the political so-called political
spectrum
um speaking in different ways. I mean
some people have become much more
emboldened
u from you know the right-wing and some
people have become
you know the opposite from the left and
then you have Muslims saying whatever
they're saying. uh I haven't really had
the time to look at all the responses
but I wanted to approach this in a
completely different way and that is to
tackle this notion
this false notion in my view of freedom
of speech and expression now what do I
mean it's a false notion I think it's a
phantom notion I think it's a useful
fiction I think it's a western mythology
the way it's being presented the way
it's used as a slogan okay I think it's
actually a fiction let me explain why
When people come out and say we want
freedom of speech and expression, what
are they actually calling for? They are
calling and this is the only thing they
can call for the government to remove
limitations on things like hate speech,
on things like racism or whatever it may
be that uh prevents or otherwise
inhibits an individual from um saying
whatever they want to say so long as
they don't want to harm anyone else. the
social liberal sense and that's of
course the harm principle. That's what
they're calling for. But in so doing
they are they're assuming actually the
presupposition is that freedom of speech
and expression is the sole
um property in a sense or it's exercised
only by the government. freedom of
speech and expression. And I don't want
anyone in what I'm about to say to
misinterpret what I'm going to say
because obviously I'm a Muslim guy.
People are going to say this guy is
saying this that and the other.
Freedom of expression is not okay
something the government controls
because the assumption here is that the
government has all the power in a given
society where we know that actually
there are different parties that have
different power. There are different
stakeholders of power and when I was
doing my undergraduate in politics, this
is actually the first thing
I learned. I had done an undergraduate
and I can remember the first year and I
think it was the first lesson okay where
they taught us what is referred to as
like um theories of power and I remember
Robert Dahl his definition is you know
the power is person A's ability to get
person B to do what person B would
otherwise not do and then they
contrasted this with like backrats and
Barretts and other uh individuals who
actually said no power is more
distributed and most analysts said
actually this is a prop a more proper
definition of what power is. Obviously,
Michael Fuko took it to another level,
but we're not going there now. Um, in
terms of power, it's more distributed,
etc. And I think there is an element of
truth in that in that proposition that
actually power is more distributed in
society. Now why am I mentioning this
and linking it to the fact that freedom
of speech and expression is in fact okay
a phantom and fictional fictionalized
concept that the white man of the west
has made almost a religious concept is
because look power in any given society
is in the hands of the government. Yes,
but also in the hands of multinationals
or of the hands of bankers in the hands
of the gangsters. You don't want to
admit this, especially in a place like
America, especially where you're saying
you can have gun rights and stuff. And
actually Kirk was one of those people.
There is a clip of him saying something
effective and I'm not going to play it
because it's people going to miss you
know that uh if people have to die for
this is it's fine, you know. So which is
quite ironic actually considering that
he died for it himself. Um having said
that now if power is distributed in that
that way that we've just discussed then
freedom of speech is not a concept that
can be actualized or realized or
materialized
in any meaningful sense in society
because there will always be a group of
people who decide not to obey the law.
that their rational analysis, their
costbenefit analysis is that actually
I'm going to go against the law and in
order to delete the influence, let's
say, of my political adversary, we're
not going to play by the rules of the
social contract and we're going to a
more an anarchical position. Okay?
there's always going to be a group of
people that consider that to be a
favorable option for them and or their
cause. And therefore, freedom of speech
if you have societies with especially if
you have societies with mega populations
like America is something which actually
cannot be realized in the full sense.
Now having known this point and it's
very important that you understand that
the reason why this is the case is
because the government does not control
is not the sole administrator
uh or the sole um arbiter of freedom of
speech in the society. If you understand
this and it's actually multiple sources
and actually it comes from different
stakeholders and whatever. If you
understand this point then you realize
that sloganering on behalf of freedom of
speech now we need freedom of speech and
this and that and the other is almost a
fruitless exercise
because you're asking the government to
do something which is not in their
power. This guy Charlie Kirk was
connected to Donald Trump. Donald Trump
he was basically with all due respect
his mascot. Every day he was speaking
about him. every day he was like, you
know, I'd see a tweet that he was saying
things about this and that and the
other. He was a close friend of Donald
Trump. Yet Donald Trump, who had
recently been uh attempted
and attempted that assassination has
been attempted on him, Donald Trump
himself, okay, couldn't protect him
despite the fact that he was in an
environment that was similar to the one
that Donald Trump was in before he got
shot. But Donald Trump didn't take the
precaution and say, "Cuz this guy's a
firm supporter of me. Therefore, someone
who would want to kill me would also
want to kill him, okay? Because he's a
very influential person." He mentioned
it himself, very influential to the
youth and so on.
And if they hate me, then they hate him.
The security was abysmal. He was
with all due respect, I mean, America
really has to reassess how they're
dealing with guns here. Like you got 330
million people in a country or maybe
more now. I don't know. I haven't looked
at the population and we're we're
hearing it's it's an unsafe. I wouldn't
want to live in America. I'm sorry to
say it's an unsafe country. Especially
not as an influencer. Especially not as
an influencer that discusses politics
and religion. America becomes one of the
the most unsafe countries that you can
imagine because you don't know who's
carrying a gun.
is too much.
Okay, so that's another issue. Donald
Trump really should have protected his
man a lot more than that. He should be
blamed by the far right. He should be
blamed because he was a there was an
attempted assassination on him and he
didn't even put the precautions in place
for his major uh uh uh you know
supporters and so on and so forth. But
that's something else.
What I'm saying to you is the following
is that if you know now, if we know, if
we as a society know or as people know
that freedom of speech is a phantom and
fictionalized, romanticized, idealized
concept, it's a religious concept really
because it's connected to classical
liberalism in one way or another.
And that mentioning it so much in slogan
is actually a fruitless enterprise
because there's so many different
stakeholders of it and all the things
that we just mentioned. If you know that
then what is it then? You should know
that there is a limit to what you can
and can't say or should and shouldn't
say in terms of selfcensorship. There
should be a limit to that because if you
know that okay well if I say this about
this group of people I'm putting myself
in danger. I this is an advice to myself
like me by going out and speaking about
Islam and the Gazian genocide and the
Rohingyian genocide and the wea
genocide. Right? There are so many
enemies to me, right? I understand that
that carries a risk.
Okay? But when you're especially when
you talk about politics and religion,
you understand that that carries a risk.
From our perspective as Muslims, we have
this concept of martyrdom
which people once again they distort
this concept which is that if you die in
this context like someone shoots you or
something then you're a m you actually
are a
prophetam said it himself that whoever
dies protecting his wealth or self or
his family etc. He's a shahid. He's a m.
And so this idea for us is that's what
gives me comfort. Okay. That somewhat if
I go out like that it's fine. No
problem. I mean it's I get to the
highest level of religious uh you know
ranking. Okay. But
what I'm trying to say to you is that
there is a heavy taxation for all of us
influencers across the world. Wherever
your politics is and whatever your
religion is. Yeah. There's a heavy
taxation for taking and agitating to a
certain level. There's a heavy taxation.
If I go far enough, there's going to be
people who want to who want me dead.
There are things I could say online that
would would make people want to shoot me
and and and stab me. I've probably said
of those things already,
but that's why
do not hide behind
this idea of freedom of speech. Freedom
of speech in your understanding cannot
it's not just that it does not it cannot
exist because there's always going to be
a group of people who are criminal and
who would like to take the law in their
own hands and their costbenefit analysis
is always going to be that it's
favorable for them to do so. And so what
this thing about Charlie Kirk's murder
has shown us is
that even if you are connected to the
political administration, the political
elite, to Donald Trump, to the
establishment,
you cannot be safe. You cannot be there
is no safety. Okay? There's no safety.
And if we know that, then at least what
we should do is we can offer our
disagreements with people that are
political and religious adversaries or
whatever it may be. But there has to be
we have to temper or we have to like
be a bit careful not to go too far and
not to create societal division because
this would be one of many murders by the
way if we continue if this the far right
growth continues because the far right
is inviting the far left now to respond
and it's going to become it could even
become a civil war in your country if it
continues in the United States for
example if this continues for many many
many years it could actually become
somewhat of a a any civil war. The only
way to stop that is to realize, okay,
well, actually, we need to all respect
one another. Don't go too far. The far
right can't can't come out and speak the
way that they're speaking against uh
ethnics and against racial minorities
and against religious minorities and
Muslims because eventually this is going
to come this is going to be very bad for
everyone. Okay? Uh the far left can't
respond in that way as well. If this
continues, it's going to be very bad for
everyone. That's the lesson to learn
from this. And another lesson is if you
want to speak about politics, religion,
then know that this is the ultimate
price that any of us can face at any
time. And there is no protection from it
uh with Allah's will. But as Muslims,
the greatest protection is the idea of
martyrdom itself. And that to be honest
is a beautiful thing. Wasalam alaykum.
And I hope you understand that I'm not
advocating for anything uh particularly.
I know people are going to be taking
this outcome, but I don't care anyway.
I've said what I've said.